BRET?
>> Bret: JACQUI HEINRICH LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
THANK YOU.
LET'S BRING IN BRIT HUME TO
DISCUSS WHAT WE ARE LEARNING
ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN DURING
THIS CRISIS.
GOOD EVENING, BRIT.
FOR 30,000 FEET HERE, WHAT DO
YOU THINK THIS SAYS ABOUT
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HIS LEADERSHIP,
AND WHERE IT GOES FROM HERE?
>>
>> WELL, BRET, I THINK PEOPLE
HAVE TO BEGIN NOW TO ASSESS
WHETHER THIS PRESIDENT WAS THE
MAN, THE PRESIDENT THEY THOUGHT
HE WAS AND WOULD BE AFTER ALL
THIS WAS THE SEASONED FOREIGN
POLICY EXPERT, FORMER CHAIRMAN
OF THE SENATE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE, A POST HE HELD TWICE.
THE KIND OF MAN THEY BELIEVED, I
THINK, WOULD NOT MAKE SERIOUS
FOREIGN POLICY MISTAKES.
AND, YET, THIS IS THE FIRST BIG
FOREIGN POLICY ISSUE OF HIS
PRESIDENCY, THE FIRST BIG
CRISIS, AND THE CONDEMNATION OF
IT HAS BEEN VIRTUALLY UNANIMOUS
ACROSS THE BOARD, INCLUDING MANY
DEMOCRATS.
NOT TO MENTION THAT IT HAS
GOTTEN A LEVEL OF CRITICISM FROM
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA ONE RARELY
SEES DIRECTED AT A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT.
NOT TO MENTION THE FACT THAT THE
PUBLIC CAN SEE WITH ITS OWN EYES
ALL THE THINGS, NEARLY ALL THOSE
THINGS THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN TOLD
US WOULD NOT HAPPEN IN
AFGHANISTAN HAVE NOW COME TO
PASS.
YES, INKEYED, IT WAS A
REMARKABLE EVACUATION MISSION, A
REMARKABLE RESPONSE TO AN
EMERGENCY, BUT IT WAS AN
EMERGENCY CREATED BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION IN A WAY THAT IT
HANDLED THE EVACUATION.
AND WE KNOW NOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT REPEATEDLY OVERRULED
HIS MILITARY ADVISERS AS TO HOW
TO CONDUCT THIS EVACUATION.
SO IT SEEMS TO ME THAT THERE IS
A REAL CHANCE HERE THAT PEOPLE
ARE LOOKING AT THIS PRESIDENT IN
AN TELLING NEW LIGHT AND MAY NOT
SEE HIM THE SAME AGAIN.
>> Bret: YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY,
THE FOCUS IS ON THE AMERICANS ON
THE GROUND, THE AFGHAN ALLIES
WHO WORKED WITH US TRYING TO GET
THOSE PEOPLE OUT WHO WANT TO GET
OUT.
BUT, IN THE POLITICAL SPHERE, A
LOT OF TIMES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
AMERICANS LOSING INTEREST,
TURNING THE PAGE, YOU KNOW,
CLOSING THE CHAPTER, AND MOVING
ON.
OBVIOUSLY THE ADMINISTRATION
WOULD LIKE THAT TO HAPPEN, IS IT
GOING TO HAPPEN WITH SOMETHING
LIKE AFGHANISTAN IN THIS
HANDLING?
>> WELL, AS LONG AS THERE ARE
AMERICANS THERE THAT WANT TO GET
OUT AND CANNOT OR HAVE NOT
GOTTEN OUT, AND THERE ARE TALES
OF ATROCITIES BY THE TALIBAN,
WHICH I EXPECT WILL MULTIPLY INN
THE DAYS AHEAD EVEN SUCH WE
DON'T HAVE NEWS COVERAGE COMING
OUT OF THERE, WORD GETS OUT.
IT WOULD BE HARD FOR THE ISSUE
TO FADE COMPLETELY ANY TIME
SOON, WHICH IS NOT TO SAY THAT
OVER TIME PEOPLE'S MEMORY OF IT
WON'T FADE, BUT THEY WILL, I
THINK, REMEMBER FOR A VERY LONG
TIME THE SHAKY CHARACTER WHO
CAME OUT AND MADE THESE BOGUS
EXPLANATIONS OF WHAT WAS
HAPPENING AND WHY IT HAPPENED,
SAID THINGS THAT WERE PROBABLY
NOT TRUE AND WAS CALLED ON THEM.
SO THE QUESTION COMES, YES,
PEOPLE MAY STOP THINKING ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN AS SUCH IT REALLY IS
A GOOD QUESTION WHETHER THEY
WILL EVER LOOK AT JOE BIDEN THE
SA